nein nein du arbeitest nicht bei
goldesel goldesel ist keinen job hat das
ist so ein falsches bild was davon
mittel seien deswegen muss man dieses
videos machen leute das erste wird die
fashion show aller zeiten geht an maria
ledig rowohlt in dem video dann
aktiviert einfach die benachrichtigung
für meinen kanal verlegt auf die glocke
und macht danach die wahnsinn main kanal
und kommentiert immer wieder dass wir
die belastung an gemacht hat dann kriegt
ihr vielleicht schon im nächsten video
auch das und ihr solltet die lautstärke
für das video fest bisschen runter
machen kann er manchen stellen bisschen
lauter werden features kommen zu einem
neuen video leute in den letzten tagen
gegner wiederum in den letzten tagen und
wochen eingespielt so bietet ein und
fühlen sich viele von euch ans ausland
gesehen hat ist wahrscheinlich keine
ahnung von ich werde aber nicht sagen
dass deine werbung ist damit sehr
wahrscheinlich dass ich meine was heute
hier um die geile werben von goldesel
wird ganze durch youtube video das boot
auf dem kanal erol thaqi hochgeladen der
kanal eigentliche tausend abonnenten
aber das video hat 25 millionen aufrufe
alter wie funktioniert das ganz einfach
du wolltest wie von dem typen online ist
hat das unternehmen was ihr da gold
diese steckt einfach fett fett fett
kohle in die werbung reingepumpt damit
ihr die werbung sieht deswegen hat es
viele aufrufe dazu mal vorneweg wickelte
die leute werden
[Musik]
als einen der gründe warum ich ein video
möglich das video machen muss und war
wahrscheinlich auch dafür mit solchen
job suchen kann es sein in welchem jahr
sind wir eigentlich ist das jahr 2017
leute keiner muss mehr arbeiten die
ganzen chefs der großen dax 30
unternehmen den größten unternehmen
deutschlandweit sogar die machen es alle
falsch die arbeit noch brauchen
[Musik]
denkst du ernsthaft eine app fallen
einen job ersetzen denke ich mir einfach
man kann mit einer app so viel geld
verdienen wie man in einem ehrlichen job
funktioniert wie die der gerne geld
schenken wollten dafür haben sie diese
app gegründet als gemeinnützigen zweck
ich glaube ich nicht richtig freuen
wählen sie jetzt okay leute ein prinzip
hinter dieser app ist dass man sich
werbung anschauen dass man dafür geld
bekommt okay jetzt gesagt man bekommt 30
kein werde ich jetzt richtig ärgerlich
dass videos wie ich schon mal gesehen
sind 30 konz umgerechnet 35 aber nicht
bar sondern in ärmeren gutscheinen 3
wenn du kommst für eine handlung die
wahrscheinlich ein oder zwei minuten
dauert 3 cent auf die stunde umgelegt
mal 30 genommen oder wisst ihr was kommt
wir machen wir vor 60 jahren nur
großzügig 63 ist ein stundenlohn von 1
eur 80 werde mir sagen leute dass eine
app bei der man wenn man die komplett
durch die pro stunde ein euro 80
verdient den job ersetzen kann
der mindestlohn in deutschland bei 8
euro 50 ok oft überhaupt erreichen
diese botschaft der gerade drei cent
verdient und läuft mit zwei nagelneuen
tüten reihen der durchfahrt drei seen
finden warum kaufst du diese ab und
kaufte mir sachen was 3 cent verdient
das ist keine gelegenheit um beim saturn
anita fetz aufzugehen okay ist die
gelegenheit sich einen anderen job zu
suchen
langsam werde ich richtig getriggert
alter schwede betrieb läuft gerade ein
mit einer kamera von sa2 stellt eine
einfache rechnung auf sagen wir eine
kamera für viel raum für die kamera die
google ist gibt viele kameras mehr als
1000 euro kosten
okay sagen immer großlagen verdient
einen euro 8 mg pro stunde wenn er die
welt folglich ballert das grob
überschlagen er musste für diese kamera
200 stunden lang werbung schauen das
sind fast zehn tage ohne schlaf in dinge
durchgehend werbung schaut mitte das was
ganz ehrlich danach könnt ihr euren im
mixer truck und das macht dann auch
keinen unterschied mehr
wie viele menschen wurden von dieser
linie die viele menschen haben ihre
arbeit aufgegeben familienväter ihre
familie versorgt haben mütter die für
ihre kinder besorgt um alle in der viele
leute die hart gearbeitet haben ihren
job und für die familie sorgen haben
ihren job aufgegeben auch nicht hetzen
mittels barth ingo esel ihr unterhalt
verdienen bist du jetzt warum die 20
sekunden bauen wird muss nicht mal auf
die werbung klicken einfach nur auf sex
tritten und rausch vom 30 oder ich hab
mich enttäuscht meine ganze berechnung
waren falsch man kann mit wieder
unschöne app tatsächlich
m 30 sekunden verdienen statt in einer
minute geteilt es heißt der stundenlohn
wenn man durchgehend werden schauten weg
was kein mensch macht auf der ganzen
welt aber egal wenn man durch den
währungs und direkt danach wechselt kann
man in der stunde leute richtig
verdienen
ich weiß mich läuft jetzt leute drei
euro 60 pro stunde
wenn ich durch geht wären sauer und mir
mein komplettes gehirn der ballade von
werbung gibt es teure amazon gutschein
dafür braucht es 1000 credits 10 euro
mass und gut 10.000 ist und es geht ja
einige einfach besser
333 werbung anschauen welche sachen
leichtes geld
hier arbeitet nicht bei goldesel
goldesel ist kein job egal
das ist so ein falsches bild was dafür
mittel seien deswegen muss man dieses
video zu machen ist eine 11
ich habe dafür bezahlt dass du dir
werbung anschaut den ganzen tag das
problem ist viele von euch denken wer
glaubt niemand dass doch noch richtig
viele leute die keine 12 13 14 sind
fünften vielleicht 16 6 nicht so selbst
reflektiert sind also die ihr leben
nicht sogar denken und das sehen denken
sich nie wieder arbeiten
nein für einen das beste vor allem ist
die sache richtig gekennzeichnet sein
video was ich in seiner gänze nur um
diese app dreht und deswegen weil es die
ganze zeit um ein gewisses produkt geht
für das er bezahlt wurde muss bis ganze
video oben wäre wie du stehen falsch
gekennzeichnet noch mal einfach um
werbevideo aber er ist auch irgendwann
egal oder alles deute ich will wirklich
nicht gegen das unternehmen hätten aber
bitte installiert wird die welt nicht so
katja francz oft ganz ehrlich also ich
glaube die botschaft von dem videos
verstand jungen könnt ihr uns überlegt
also abdecken zwei leute unterzeichnet
endlich mal kirche